hey everybody and welcome to a surprise
wild ride with stevo that's right nobody
expected this to drop on a monday
but it did because we want to give
everyone a chance to catch it before the
big fight this weekend
what big fight it's jake paul versus
this week's guest ben askren that's
right i mean it's
about as big a thing in the youtube
world the mma world
i mean in the world so this one's really
exciting
and big thanks to ben askren for
squeezing us into his schedule because
man his life is pretty crazy right now
let's check it out
ladies and gentlemen ben askren yeah
dude
how's it going brother i'm doing pretty
good
uh i've got work out on this morning and
then go hang out my family this
afternoon
awesome man great i want you to meet my
co-host scott randolph i know you guys
just
introduced each other talking about
alaska before what's up scott
up at the front of the van we've got the
gorgeous paul briskey
what's going on ben how are you yeah i'm
doing well
great to meet you and and man thank you
so much for doing this dude but
we've never met i just tweeted at you
i'm a big fight
fan i'm with the whole mma community
just like
counting on you to win this big fight
going on
well i'm a big jackass fan i you know i
used to do the pranks and [ __ ] in high
school
um you know emulating you guys i didn't
get quite as crazy you know my favorite
one was
put dog [ __ ] in a purse so you put a
couple dollar bills hanging out and
almost always
the car would stop pick up the dog [ __ ]
and they'd drive off and then you know
like a minute later you'd see them going
ah
it's dog [ __ ] yeah the old two dollars
that's
that's a variation of the poo dollar i'm
not aware of
um so yeah dude uh i guess my
my first question would be um
win lose or draw does this jake paul
fight earn you
more money than your whole previous
fight career
comparable less uh i'm making more for
one fight than i ever have before yes
it's
it man it's interesting the way the
world works because like
oh i retired and i meant it and i said
hey you know something interesting
happens i'll probably come out and do it
but
i that meant an mma fight to me or
possibly a wrestling match because
that's my background
at no point did i think i'd be boxing a
youtuber but um
they you know they at first it was kind
of like funny thing on social media and
then they called me
it's like i don't know sounds like fun
time to me
and they're gonna pay me a whole bunch
of money i don't think why wouldn't i do
it
it's a no-brainer um so so that's really
interesting to me
you said uh getting paid more than i've
ever been paid for a fight
but you've had many many fights in your
career
right so yeah this is just two
22 when you just began professional
fighting mm-hmm
and you're 36 now yes wow dude
that's uh yeah so this is just another
fight it's
the highest paying fight but it's not
like this is the the biggest payday
like compared to everything put together
because i i no not knocking no not
compared to put that
everything put together just just single
singular fight um
and you know to me it's i don't want to
say well i
oh a dog nice i should have brought my
dog she's upstairs
um i don't want to say less interesting
but um you know in mma my whole purpose
was to prove i was
the best in the world and i never quite
got there you know i went belton uh
bellator and won championship and i
never quite
quite got the title in the ufc but that
was kind of the whole purpose of every
fight
mattered you know and now this is like
hey it's a boxing match like
if i win outstanding if i lose and that
sucks
but i never like wanted to be the best
box in the world i never i never even
thought i was going to be a boxer right
this
happened exactly i got to say too that
in defeat i think that's what you really
wanted me over man when you had that
crushing knockout with moz vidal
and you just immediately got on twitter
and tweeted well that sucked yeah i just
[ __ ] fell in love with that dude i
mean i honestly
i honestly i i'm sure you know but like
people handle defeat in different ways
you know and i just thought that that
was indicative of a
really well-adjusted guy with humility
and like hey man you know what do you
want that sucked
and uh yeah you know that won me over
and you know what i mean hey dude
i i enjoy fighting i i enjoy the whole
game
and uh i respect you a lot man so again
thank you for doing this
yeah i appreciate it so are you guys
really surfing in alaska because that
seems like maybe like
you could go somewhere better to surf
yeah by the time this airs we're going
to be surfing in alaska
like we will be yeah they're that's so
funny even though right now we're like
100 feet from the beach
like we're very close radio we're parked
we're like thank available i heard it
was 39 i don't know
well 39 40. but yeah is there like
better waves there or
what i mean why i think the waves are
going to be decent
and and uh i got into surfing a while
back i suck at it terribly
but i got into a hobby of traveling the
world and getting photographs of surfing
in different countries and i call this
my surf passport
it's been a little bit of a bucket list
item for me to get a photo
surfing on a wave with fully
snow-covered mountains in the background
and uh this is this is what it's all
about it's a
singular and purpose well we had this
trip planned like a year ago then the
pandemic hit
and then the guy hit us up he's like hey
so you guys still planning to come next
week and we're like oh [ __ ] we still got
to go to alaska
ah that's fine i love what i went to i
went to
seward actually my my thing was i was
going to national parks
um in the united states and then i said
before 30
and then i said only in the continental
us but i did go to a few in alaska
um and we went to the one just
it's off right off seward and it's
called kenai fjords
and i got to see a glacier like fl flop
out in the water and it was like the
most badass thing ever it was so
freaking cool
wow yeah we fly into anchorage we drive
to seward we get on a boat
and we're going to be just cruising
around on a boat for three or four days
i think it's safe to say that nobody
gives a [ __ ] about what we're going to
do in alaska
we got ben asking here i got i care
about it
for the people who are watching this
rather than just listening can we get a
better look at this incredible robe
you're wearing
yeah this so i got i got this given to
me by one of my sponsors yesterday and
like
you know i i kind of feel ridiculous
wearing it right now but
it is like the most comfortable thing
ever so uh i was actually
i got i got i got home i worked out i
showered it's kind of like rainy and
shitty so i was cold so like oh my
i'm gonna throw that robe on and i'm
like i'm gonna look ridiculous when i go
on the show and i'm like yeah
are you gonna wear this coming out it
like as if it looks like something a
boxer would wear
yeah yeah yeah cool
do you have your do you have your
walkout music already picked so i've had
the same thing since i've been a
sophomore
in college uh and it's we want the funk
there you go i did it i love it now you
said one of my sponsors
gave me this robe um how many sponsors
you got how does that work
oh i i got a question so ufc
ufc you can't really have any in-cage
sponsorship you know
they kind of control it all at the top
uh but with this i've been able to get a
whole bunch so i got a ton of
i don't like seven maybe i'm not i'm not
sure is that part of the reason manager
helen is that
he's they're all my shorts is that part
of the reason why boxers make more money
because they're allowed more spawn
outside sponsorships
well so i i would i would like to see
the math i think
boxers at the very very top make way
more money
but then in the middle and lower rungs i
think mixed martial artists are
significantly more well paid i mean i i
know i've seen really high level boxing
fights where
at the bot you know the top is many
millions at the bottom it's like one
thousand dollars
for the fight and ufc base pay is
uh 12 to show up in 12 to win so ufc the
lowest the lowest of the low in ufc is
dollars for a fight if you win yeah i
did good
got you so uh that you answered my
question the the sponsors are
for this fight in particular correct
yeah yeah
well i mean i have a few things for
other stuff that i you know like see i
do uh
i do a crypto podcast on monday and i
have sponsors for that
for example nice are you guys into
crypto yeah we're we're
we're getting into doing an nft so we're
getting ready to launch
uh steve's first nft i don't think that
that really i mean i guess
ethereum is a cryptocurrency is that
right yeah but it's it's related right i
mean if we're stuck
in blockchain i don't really love so i'm
actually doing an
ft but i don't personally love nfts but
i always say like
who am i to judge what other people
think is valuable
um you know and that's kind of what nfts
are is they
people see them as scarce assets that
are going to be
you know one of a kind or or a very
limited amount
and that they're going to be worth a lot
more and you know 5 10 15 20 years
so but the reason why i brought that up
was because i invested into ethereum
because nfps are so popular right now
because because i figured like it's the
currency and
it's only going to go up if more people
buy right if tom brady's having a yes
nft gallery
more people are going to be using the
ethereum you like ethereum
i do yeah theorem's great i mean they
that's uh
man it's the second biggest after
bitcoin i don't actually view it as like
a currency it's a smart contract
platform so there's just so many things
that can be done there um
i don't know and i guess maybe some
people argue and say it is a currency i
don't really think it is but
yeah it's great it's a tremendous way up
in value i think how long have you been
into cryptocurrency is this a recent
thing or have you been on
it for a minute i got in in 2017
i read killed one of my friends a long
long time ago
about stuff i probably can't say on air
because you know you guys get pulled off
youtube or some [ __ ]
um wow and then in 2017
he said hey there's this thing called
bitcoin here's what it's all about
and i got it right away you know like i
just i don't like the fed i
don't like the politicians controlling
our money and the bitcoins out of the
scope of the politicians so i understood
it immediately and i loved it
all right wow so you got in on bitcoin
in 2017. i would imagine that's looking
pretty good now
it's looking very good wow telling us
ben that you're rich
i don't know if i'm stevo rich but i'm
doing pretty well in life yeah
yeah what is the definition of rich like
at what point in money do you like
i'm rich is it like one million is it
five million
well i always feel like it's um it's
arbitrary based on your spending habits
because like say
you know mike tyson's the most famous
case he made 400 million dollars but he
got used to spending
many million millions a year and then
also he had none you know so it's like
you know if you spend five million
dollars a year you're gonna need to make
at least six million to be rich but if
you spend
you know 250 000 a year you're only
going to make 500 000 in your bridge
and that's very astute i like that yeah
and i love david
you're talking about the cryptocurrency
i believe this in these theories and
that's just what mark cuban told you
last year
was so late to the party mark cuban was
bashing
crypto till like two months ago or
something yeah yeah
are we late to the party like that's how
i feel buying crypto i'm like ah like
maybe i'll get something out of it but
it feels like maybe i'm too late or is
the big
burst still yet to happen you think like
the beach well i think it's like the
future like i mean maybe i'm a little
too far down the rabbit hole but i think
like bitcoin is going to be the world
reserve currency in the next 10 years
wow
well i think it'll be something other
than the american dollar that's
for sure this really smart guy named
michael saylor was on my podcast
he bought he he trained to turn his
whole company's cash reserves into
bitcoin
and he simply said to me and this is the
best line of i've heard in like 70
episodes he said
ben who do you trust to make your money
the politicians are the engineers
yeah and i i came into the warehouse
yesterday and i told somebody that i
bought ethereum and and
you know asked me if he was in the
cryptocurrency and he's like dude
dogecoin all the way
and i looked into dogecoin and it's a
it's a fake currency that they made up
that like blew up is that
is that what it is um so i would just
say
dogecoin doesn't do anything you in my
mind doesn't do anything unique that
bitcoin or some of the other ones can't
do um but it's got this really cool logo
so it's like i call it a meme coin like
you know uh elon musk tweets about it
and then it goes up like
600 percent because i think when elon
musk tweeted about it it was worth less
than a penny per coin
oh you know so someone can go oh i'm
buying a thousand dollars coin
and they spent like 10 bucks or
something wow
okay so on this jake paul fight
when it gets like uh the the
pay-per-view is gonna
probably be bigger well the last
pay-per-view that jake paul fought on
was where mike tyson came out of
retirement to do the exhibition match
with roy jones jr and how many was that
that was
that was like a monumentally [ __ ] big
like what was it like two point
something million buys i yeah i feel
like two million which is i mean which
for a pay-per-view is
like insane what was logan uh uh ksi and
logan paul
that was a different deal because it was
on triller
which one is this one no i thought that
was wasn't that one on youtube i know
that wasn't always on days or something
like
i don't know what it was on or mike
tyson was on trailer
but it was like a proper like fifty
dollar buy for a pizza
you got that's what this one is too
right so how many views was that like
how many uh paper or buy
it was 2 million times 50 like
ben yeah what's that that's 100 million
dollars okay good
holy [ __ ] and uh and and so this one
doesn't have
like mike tyson's coming out of
retirement like
but it's got it's all mma community i
was watching it the entire mma community
boxing like do we have a projection for
how many buys
that's that's not that's not my arab
experience right no we don't but they
also they're also trying to do it's like
kind of like to do something different
you know i'm just there to fight but
they're doing these concerts too so like
bieber's bieber's performing
oh my god other really really i just
like some of the other people like are
really popular but i don't
it's kind of like not my era so i don't
i don't really know them you know i'm
like
right uh dmx and rest in peace
red hot chili peppers kind of guy right
okay yeah wow
yeah and that was a big big component to
the mike tyson one
um and and i'm buddies with mike tyson i
love
his his guy rob and and i reached out
like just dying to know what these music
musical artists were being paid
a lot and that would be a lot right
between every
every fight there was like was it wiz
khalifa i mean i i don't know
i don't know you know he didn't tell me
like from an artist
an artist or artist but uh but
absolutely the budget for
the musical performances was in
significantly in the millions
[ __ ] if i'm gonna pay more bieber i'll
be so freaking pumped
that's so good but uh do you do you have
any
like even a small percentage of uh of
interest in the actual pay-per-view like
you know no i didn't get a percentage um
you know again for me it was like this
they offered me a lot of money and it
was
uh sounded like fun you know i used to
box my friends for
for free on friday nights and i thought
it was a good time like hey that was a
fun night
right now sometimes they pay me a
gigantic amount of money to do that i
figured i'd say yes
i mean hey dude i i'm rooting for you i
see the philosophy of it
and um you know like i feel like wait
stevo did you guys do some boxing
episodes on jackass i feel like you did
i did we did stilt boxing yeah you
fought
me against ryan dunn on stilts and uh i
remember
that and then knoxville fought
butterbean in the store
and he took punches from butterfly and
he snored right yeah that was uh
that that was tough to watch um you know
i thought and and you know forgive me
but i think i'm with a lot of people
that i thought
as far as like who in the professional
fighting world jake paul could have
called
out that it was like really rather
genius to say oh i'll box ben askren
yeah because of course
your your strength is is with wrestling
um
and i mean it is [ __ ] pretty pretty
genius and
now having said that i think that that
really squarely makes
you really important in the equation
because
you know if you're looking for an
advantage in boxing
then like who else do you have other
than ben askren who is a huge name
in combat sports but like notoriously
not for striking there's not really
anybody else i think he could have got
a percentage yeah uh i mean
i just like i'm doing well in life so i
wasn't all that
concerned about it um seemed fair
so i said yes uh they were going they're
really going after dylan dannis who's
like mcgregor's lackey
and he's got a pretty good social media
following but you know i i did bring
this up with
um in the press conference jake was like
a child he wouldn't shut up and let me
talk
um i saw that yeah i watched some of
that too that's so bad so he's kind of
like a bully though and it's like
you know i was i was retired i was four
months three and a half months out of my
hip surgery
so i was not training at all so yeah
obviously he wasn't trying to pick the
toughest guy he could pick he was trying
to pick
the easiest guy which could give him
some legitimacy
right um and i think that's pretty
obvious for me to zoom out and just
see that you know for sure um and that
being said even being
the easiest guy he can pick i think it's
probably still
too tough of a guy i think he's gonna
get in there and um
you know i think boxing is strange i've
been in
i've been in boxing like three months
now the community's kind of strange i
think he's got these guys around him who
are just telling him that
he's the best in the world he's so good
and to the point where he's almost
started to believe it and so when he
gets in you know in front of someone and
they won't go away and they're fighting
back
he's going to start panicking he's not
really really know what to do can you
talk about your game plan at all
yeah you want the scoop well here at
wild ride
we give you the scoop so you got the
scoop what else do you got do you got
bush oh man i feel sorry for you if you
do
but i know for a fact that if you've got
your manscaped products
bush isn't going to be a problem this
summer now is it
let me tell you this lawnmower 3.0
yeah i've had it for ages i've been
using it like crazy
still going strong i mean sure i can
charge it when i need to but i can't
believe the battery on this thing
i also can't believe how effective it is
at
trimming my pubic afro yeah
dude i'm telling you man i'm ready to
have my ball sack in a ball sack beauty
contest
because this thing trims it so nice
plus it smells great too because i've
got my manscaped ball deodorant
i'm telling you if you're not taking
care of your nether regions with
manscape
you're blowing it and guess what i got a
special deal for you
exclusive if you go to manscape.com
stevo you're getting 20 off your order
and free shipping you can't beat it plus
it's summertime time to wear a little
less time to get naked a little sooner
yeah you want to look good so one more
time go to manscape.com
stevo for 20 off your order and free
shipping
now let's get that scoop you know
because we've never seen him take a
punch
and we know that you've been hit and you
keep going
and that's your advantage too is that
like you've been in the fire before
yeah i mean so my my strategy would
obviously be to get close and make it a
tough fight i'm not gonna stand and try
to have pretty boxing
um get in there and make it ugly make it
dirty land kind of like the dirty boxing
clinch strikes that type of stuff and
yeah to
that point we've never seen him really
go very long we've never seen him
against someone good
we've never seen him get hit we've never
seen him get tired
so there's all these big big question
marks with him right like how is he
what's going to happen and listen i said
i i i was at freddie roaches and i boxed
with one really really good guy
i'm like dude i don't want to be in
there with that guy that guy's gonna
[ __ ] kill me
like you know so if for some reason he
is like the best in the world it's gonna
be a long night for me
i just i think that's like really really
really unlikely
i think it's incredible that it's such a
mystery that we that we don't know
and that's probably why it's gonna do so
well how's the training different
from this in in mma like how you're not
weight cutting or are you weight cut
like what
what's no yeah i'm not weight cutting
because it's like
hey you're gonna find a youtuber it's
not like there's some legal i get to
pick what weight class i'm gonna go it's
like hey there's there's this one
youtuber guy here's the weight class do
you want it or not
um so i'm finding it 190 i wrestled at
uh 174 fought at 170. so yeah it's big
for me
um what are you normally walking around
out before uh
before you cut to 170. so usually when
i'm when i'm like working out in shape
183 to 185 um i said i was retired i had
my hip surgery you guys see this badass
scar
yeah dude we love scars oh
[ __ ] that's a long one so i got my hip
redone in september
so literally like when i want to say
that pay-per-view the tyson one that
you're talking about was
um late november like i literally
wasn't allowed to do anything for three
months like
nothing nothing and then at three months
i got to start riding a bike and that
that type of thing
and so when i first you know first
started training i was really happy
because i hadn't been allowed to do
anything for like four and a half months
yeah dude with um with jake having sort
of all these yes people around him
like in some ways does that help him
i've heard mike tyson talk about like
he's like i would have to almost be like
delusional to go in these fights and
just think i'm so good like he was like
i would purposely sort of
be delusional and like is is that
unrealistic belief in yourself in some
ways a benefit
um well i i would say i think yes it is
important to have those
type of thoughts when you're going to
competition because the last thing
you want in competition is to like doubt
yourself have anxiety
um i mean for you guys you guys came
from extreme sports so it's like
you don't be on top of the half pipe
saying oh my god i'm gonna freaking fall
i'm gonna
if you're thinking like that you're
probably gonna fall you know
right you either wanna have a clear mind
where you're not really thinking about
anything
uh and you're just focused solely on the
execution of the technique
uh or you know you wanna say i'm gonna
freaking crush this one of those two
things you know
um so uh to a little bit yes it's
semi-beneficial when you step in the
ring but the the real huge
issue uh becomes is
if that doesn't come true right then
what do you do yeah yeah you
it's a 24 minute fight and it's not
coming true
then what sure you know like those guys
can't fight for him
their cheers really aren't gonna help
him in the fight like it might help him
get through training
but in a real fight it's got to be you
saying like
i'm gonna i'm gonna [ __ ] go get this
guy like i'm gonna i'm gonna i'm tough
enough yeah it can't be them
they can't help you at that point now
we've seen like
with uh any kind of like celebrity
boxing it almost
seems par for the course that like
you get some high profile professional
boxer to like be in your corner and
and train you right like yeah did uh
and and as i say that i can't think of
any examples
i was trying to help you out there i
couldn't think of it either
well like uh soulja boy was going to
fight chris brown and he teamed up
with chris brown we're gonna fight i
think they were i think they were
and uh one of them was with mike tyson
while the other one was with floyd
waymather
way better but uh but
evidently the you know maz vidal
was uh you know training jake paul for
something or other which kind of makes
no sense
um but did have you had any like you
said you
got in with a pretty good guy but if you
had any like
famous boxers like hey look at me i'm
with this guy
um i so i went out to freddie roaches
for
uh i was out there for a week it was man
it was really cool
he's uh he's brilliant um
just super smart a lot of fun but you
know what i felt like he was
um i feel like i didn't want to drag him
into the circus
like that's like a legendary honorable
coach
this is a this is a circus i don't want
to bring him to the circus
like i'll just i'm going to show up and
fight jake paul and if i could beat him
up i could beat him up if i can't
i go back to coaching wrestling like i
was doing before right
okay i mean there you go there's a
well-adjusted healthy guy
and uh and and with that i've been like
speaking of maz vidal clearly i brought
him up um
yeah do uh like i see
everything posted about moz but all via
arrow ariel helwani
like you know everything else and i
follow all the mma stuff
it just seems like the comments are
almost like universally
wow how'd this guy go from like like the
most popular guy
to like the most hated guy and like say
it's just like we've watched this like
fall
from grace this yeah this like uh
rise and fall of of mazvidal and uh
you know throughout the whole time with
all the like aggressive
[ __ ] talking he did towards you and
really just kind of disrespect
um bullying if you will
like you never seem to even like it just
seemed to roll off of you you were never
like
resentful or or anything right that's
the impression that i got
well i think uh so i think that this
it's really interesting the public
public sentiment's a really funny thing
because my wife is like
she was dying laughing last night
because it was like for a long time in
mma i was not liked because i was
outsider who who dana white didn't want
to give me my shot in the ufc and i was
kind of like
uh something i disliked you know and now
like
i guess because i'm going against jake
paul people freaking love me or maybe
it's because they got to know who i
really
am and i'm i'm still the same guy that i
was 10 years ago
maybe that's why but it's like this the
public sentiment changes so fast
um but with the george saying i actually
have the saying i think i might need to
trademark it or something
maybe make a book out of it but i use it
with my kids you never want to tie your
ego to your outcome
and so like when you're going into a
contest you can't control the outcome of
that contest you can try as hard as you
want
which is that's what i want i want great
effort right you can fight you can tr
you can prepare for it
but you can't control the outcome and
if you tie your ego to the outcome and
then all of a sudden you get an outcome
that you don't want
do you think you're a terrible person
you suck at life and the answer is like
no you're the same person so you can't
tell your ego to that
that's great in recovery we say stay out
of the results
but i i really like what do you say we
say stay out of the results
we're not in the results business you
know we're in the the intention we're in
the
the you know but tying your ego to it's
another
another level two which is great and man
i just saw this
this ridiculous thing that that uh moz
had all said
like colby covington's not a draw in any
way
like no way i'd fight him like i'm gonna
be selling out pay-per-views
he nobody wants and it was just like
okay you know yeah i i've said this a
million times that i
i'm so invested in disliking colby
covington
that i just absolutely want him to win
and win
and win and win so that he'll always be
there for me to dislike
well i would do and i would say george
does i don't think george wants to fight
colby
exactly that's exactly what's going on
if you're going to be the bmf
if you're going to be the bmf and you're
going to say your game break and you'll
fight anyone
then you fight anyone then why why are
you talking about how big of a draw it
is because
you're supposed to not care you're
supposed to be the bmf you're supposed
to say i don't really give a [ __ ]
show up on july 12th and then we'll be
there
right now supposed to make excuses that
they're not i'm not a big enough draw
it's ridiculous
right and uh it's absolutely a [ __ ]
massive draw for sure yeah yeah colby's
almost got that jake paul knit where
it's like you you want to see him lose
right because yeah
oh yeah but colby's playing so well
colby's boxing is [ __ ]
impressive when he stood with was it
marty or camaro what's the
what's the real name so listen uh and
here's
let me let me put it here on this
because i know what no one's asking me
that question
yeah when i knew him i knew i he i knew
him for a while his name was marty
like that's just it was just dude this
dude name's marty that's all like
there's
no disrespect no nothing and so when i
first got on dfc and someone asked me
about him i said something something
marty
i didn't mean anything by it i even i
think i said he was a good fighter
or some something to that effect you
know and then he [ __ ] got pissed at
me
and i'm like because by your name that
you you were like
so then of course i started taunting him
about it because he got mad so i had to
keep going right
but it's like i thought like a long time
a long long time i don't think he's cool
a long time ago
like he was just another wrestling dude
that was cool that worked hard
everything was good and like i thought
i didn't give any issue i said marty and
then he wanted to freaking fight me over
it so then i just kept calling to marty
did you ever wrestle him back in the day
no um he was a little tiny bit younger
than me
but uh and listen again this is just me
being honest and you guys can go look at
the results you want
he really wasn't that good like he
wasn't bad but he also wasn't that good
like
he wasn't challenging to make world
teams he was more like a guy that would
say like
number eight through number 12 or
somewhere in there and that that's not
my bias you can literally
there's a website called track wrestling
you can go to track wrestling you can
type in his name you can see all of his
results
so no we never wrestled all right
um going back to the your moz vidal
fight i was one like when you get
knocked out like that like what you
so i you wake up at some point you have
to learn what happened like is there
even
a memory of it you know like yeah
of the actual knockout the fight or the
knockout or that's the only time i've
ever been
stunned knocked out anything like that
in my whole life
well lawler got you pretty good i would
count lawlessness
no but i i i i in my mind
yeah who knows that maybe something's
incredible i remember the whole thing
i remember the whole thing i remember my
thought process no gaps of
everything that was going on the entire
time you know sure
um and with george i had told this story
i think a couple times now
uh but you know i i like i know i was
awake right but i wasn't like my brain
wasn't recording things
the first thing that recorded i opened
my eyes or you know or
i find everything starts clicking again
i saw luke rockhold
i thought [ __ ] luke rockhold got knocked
out i must be in the hospital
you know and then i looked up like
here's my wife and i'm like
[ __ ] am i in the hospital and she's like
yeah and then i remember like feeling
myself
and it wasn't like that sweaty grimy
feeling you have like when you worked
hard and then
you know you cool off i'm like [ __ ] it
didn't last very long huh
and she's like and i'm like oh my all
right
what happened so that's what that's the
first memory and you're awesome
yeah and then i'm like well hey i feel
fine and then they're like hey the
results are fine and then
then uh we left we went to the after
party and then did you watch the video
at all
uh yeah i mean i've seen it like a
billion times what was your reaction to
that
your first time seeing it really i don't
remember the first time i saw my wife
don't remember i think he saw him he
tweeted well that sucks
i don't remember if i saw it before
after i tweeted that that's funny
yeah so where are you now are you what
state are you in
so i live in wisconsin i'm like 25
minutes outside milwaukee
this is where i grew up i was gone for
10 years college and i coached somewhere
else right afterwards
um and then we came back and my brother
and i started wrestling academy in 2011
and now now we have five in the state of
wisconsin it's going really well
that's great and you're an avid disc
golfer i love
i have 23 holes on my property i
freaking love you guys disc golf i love
disc golf yes is it like calling a
disc golf frisbee is that like car don't
don't
call it mad at you so that's like
calling a tattoo machine a tattoo gun
yeah but it's like i don't i don't play
frisbee on it's like a it's
you're a golfer yeah that's a this is
this is i'm a disc golfer not a frisbee
golf
no call for all okay it's not the same
thing
yeah no i i i let it slide i say what
whatever you want to call it call it but
yeah i love it i've been playing for
like
i took 9th of the amateur worlds twice
in 2009 and 11 so i'm like
super deep how many hole in ones do you
have
oh i had my vlog i had my vlog guy out
yesterday
uh or not yesterday it was thursday
maybe i hit
chains twice when he was filming wow oh
it's so annoying that i didn't get an
ace
i think i have 21 total though do you
ever play at oak grove in pasadena
california
i had to play it once because that was
yeah that was one of the originals so i
did play there one time
that that's my i i have i have some some
discs in my car and i go there
everybody i've never heard you call it a
desk because
my buddy is a professional golfer and i
and i called it like let's go pray
frisbees like i don't play frisbee
and he's pissed you know but yeah i know
not to say that
and this is a like you're actually
legitimately a professional
disc golfer is that right well
i played a pro tournament one time and
then i just got too busy with life so i
haven't got to
um but this guy i met
maybe it was two years ago again brody
smith he did some other things
and he decided to be a real pro disc
golf like he goes to all the tournaments
and he's doing
he got a thousand rating which means
he's a world-class pro now
like i'm so jealous like that looks like
so much fun but i got these businesses
that i can't really leave right now so
maybe when my kids get older i can go do
it for a few months a year
all right and that's am i correct one of
sports in which you have competed
professionally
no no i i've been top ten in the world
in four sports
ah okay mma disc golf
and uh jiu jitsu nice oh wow i love how
disc golf gets in there that's great and
uh and
and i heard you're a very avid reader do
you have your favorite book of all time
oh great i don't want to mess with the
autocad my bookshelf show over there i
don't mess with audio connection
um top five i gave uh what book did i
give away uh
yesterday there's one called thinking
fast and slow that's one of my favorite
oh and the other one i gave away the
other day that i read it i think last
year and it's just
it's so good it's called anti-fragile
blend it seemed to leave
it's really sorry say that again
anti-fragile
anti-fragile so the the thought and the
thought is that every system no matter
how big small
uh or whatever it is is like and this is
pretty obvious with someone like
um say skateboarding or wrestling is
like
you have to fail to succeed right you
have to get through those failures you
have to deal with the adversity and you
have to see what works and what doesn't
work and pick the most efficient path
and so that's kind of like that's that's
kind of the theme of anti-fragile but
it's
like you know with say the restaurant
industry
um you know if there's a downturn in the
economy
25 of them go out of business well those
were the weakest 25
so we needed to get rid of those right
then when the economy comes back up
we'll have new ones filter in and then
the process will happen
a whole bunch of times i think something
like the survival of the fitness yeah
darwin's theory of evolution i like it
yeah
all right i describe that if i if i
described it wrong and talib hears it
and he
uh be heartbroken so the
the jake paul fight takes place in los
angeles is that correct
no uh-uh um it's uh
vegas oh atlanta yeah they bought they
bought the dang um
uh the georgetown stadium the jewel uh
no it's not the georgia
it's called the mercedes-benz stadium
but then there's no fans it's it's
oh [ __ ] that's the one that they were
making or that's the coolest looking
stadium yeah dude
it's like red and it looks like some
[ __ ] kind of transformer robot
yeah right off the freeway yeah so
you're fighting with no
crowd is that what you're saying correct
i get 10 guest passes jake probably
they love him more than they love me so
they probably gave him you know a
handful more uh-huh
but that's for his entourage right yes
yes because he's so insecure he needs 27
people around him cheering him at all
times
you know i i i really believe
that uh that you then i love your saying
dude like don't tie
your ego to the outcome is that right
don't yeah don't
don't tie your ego to the outcome yeah
and i believe that you're
that you live that way i think you're
gonna be just fine if
if you lose you know like and i also
believe
that jake paul you know sort of assuming
the world and i'm not even mad at jake
paul i like the guy
you know like i like yeah he's doing a
great job of whatever he's trying to do
like he's
he's obviously you can't hate on success
you know
like he's got something figured out he's
really [ __ ]
masterful in what he's doing and he's
he's taking advantage of the opportunity
to be successful
because people dislike him you know so
it's basically the colby covington
effect
and like well i'm curious i'm curious if
he's if
if it like the whole thing is a gimmick
like if the whole thing is him playing
i i'm not sold that he's this much of a
douchebag i
think that he it i don't know right i
don't know
i agree with you i agree with you i
agree with you wholeheartedly and i'll
take it a step further that when people
say
colby covington is just playing and that
uh in fact colby covington's this nice
guys
but i don't buy that because like a nice
guy doesn't
talk about women that like that you know
like in seoul
colby's not playing i've heard i've
heard negative reviews on colby
wrestling community's small and he was
three different places um
he was at iowa central then he was at um
iowa for a year he couldn't heck it
there so then he went to oregon state
and i've heard not positive reviews
on him right so people say colby
covington's just playing
i don't buy it i think he's every bit
the douche that uh but was he like that
was he like that before his makeover
that's i've heard just kind of low
integrity
kind of douchey guy but he's a great
fighter great fighter and like
he's the only fight that uh we've seen
usman in
there that wasn't like kind of at martin
yeah i mean [ __ ] that martin that i got
used mozzarella was
the worst most [ __ ] boring fight ever
i feel like people are misremembering
that because they they like
george so much that was not a
competitive fight
not at 43. all lost every round 50 43 so
he lost every round in two
two ten eights yes and ended up with all
the foot stomping
and the up against the fence like uh
yeah
i actually thought george missed on that
one i thought
and somehow he got a rematch which i i
don't think i i was against the rematch
i think doesn't make sense
i think if that night if on the night he
lost would have said hey man i got six
days to prepare for this
i need a real i need a real shot this is
crap i think he would have got it
but he didn't say that for real he he
did he did he said
let's play it back let's play it back
when i have a full camp is what he said
but yeah if there's if there was a
[ __ ]
usman 2 that you want to see it's
covington yes because that [ __ ] fight
was amazing
i broke your face i loved it
but yeah dude so uh so now um
what are we promoting for you what what
are you promoting for me
i thought i just got to come on and chat
with stevo i was so [ __ ] pumped
because i watched jackass for so many
years dude i love it man i'm a big fan
i would do i was very much excited to
talk to you as well dude like
like i said man you won me over a long
time ago and and i just i love your
[ __ ] you know you're kind of this
[ __ ] dorky cool
and i'm into that yes
you're a [ __ ] dorky cool and and and
i just love the humility man i love uh
don't tie your ego to the outcome man
that's [ __ ] fantastic
and yeah yeah i'll have a good week i'm
going to go fight jake paul and you guys
are going to alaska maybe
sometime after that we can either throw
some discs together or do
do you still do pranks or you don't do
pranks anymore i'm down it's uh it's
difficult for me
to uh expect to go under the radar a lot
of the time
and um you know but but [ __ ] dude i'm
all about it man you know i got a guy
a good friend of mine is working with uh
like an
oscar oscar-winning [ __ ] costume
designer who
identifies as a fan and says like yeah i
can i can turn you
like special effects like i can turn you
into any person
like recognizable person yeah i could
walk around as
whoever you want uh make me into crazy
monsters
so i do want to like like bring back the
prank game
like with you you'd have to choose you
should come back as ben askren and fight
jake paul for him
he's like just kidding you know
how epic would that be yeah that'd be
awesome but dude i would love it man
like uh
get together and do something man and if
i don't know if the podcast
uh the cryptocurrency and is that you
have another podcast as well
so i do i do a wrestling podcast it's
with another kind of full wrestling of
the biggest
media company wrestling so we go tuesday
wednesday thursday mornings and that
and uh are you cool with ariel helwani i
remember you talking [ __ ] about you're
great with him
you know what you had something to say
about his uh yeah
he cried he cried like little ariel you
cried like a little baby
um this was all the way back in 2012. he
talked [ __ ] on me after the douglas lima
fight
and i simply said here's what i said he
can go back and fight i said
i want to talk to you he said you can't
come on my show anymore i said good i
want to talk to you
as about as bad as you want to come in
the cage with me and he said i
threatened to fight him
i clearly did not threaten to fight him
i just said i don't want to come on your
show
um oh wow and then we made up like three
years later and we're great now
yeah and then you had some playful dig
more recently
about like uh so i think it was you're
doing a podcast and
you said like oh my podcast gets more
listeners then you're
something or other yeah but you guys are
cool
you know i know we're yeah we're cool
he's i really like ariel i really i
really do like ariel
no he's good i was listening to a chill
son and talk about
you know how when you were fighting in
uh and it was china or asia
and i thought uh singapore but i fought
in
manila shanghai dubai singapore
i think that might be it and now with
one championship on tnt they're really
american they're really americanizing it
right i was like [ __ ] i missed
like mma like what is this tnt like
yeah it will and and chill was talking
about how uh
you know he'd be shooting you a text and
he's like hey don't you have a fight
coming up soon you're like
yeah i'm next and like he's like that's
just the kind of attitude he has you
know and he's like well let me let you
go and you're like no no like what's up
let's talk for a little bit he's like
you know i'm just sitting here before my
next fight yeah are you
you're just not nervous about going into
the ring or that's how you kind of like
de-stress
or what yes yeah de-stress so actually i
mean it could get way into this this is
sports psych stuff so
um i i'm like an overthinker like my
mind is
hyperactive and so when i was really
young i had a couple really poor
performances
because i had anxiety because i was
thinking too much and one of my coaches
helped me and it was like
just don't think about it and that's why
i said like where you're like you're
saying your mind is neutral where you're
not really thinking about anything
except execution
and so i had to work on that maybe i
became really good at it and but a lot
of it was like
literally when i'm so we'll say five
minutes to
six hours before the competition i don't
want to think about the competition it's
not gonna help me
either i figured out how to fight or i
have it like i'm nothing is gonna happen
in that time window that's gonna make me
a better fighter
either i know how to go fight this guy
or i don't right yeah but what if you
what if you
throw on the eye of the tiger
what the hell for me it makes me crazy
and then i perform like [ __ ] you know so
for me it's just like about relaxing um
keeping my taking my mind off of it
right because your mind can just obsess
over
what could happen and what could happen
is it relevant to
how you're going to perform and so yeah
i mean i i got really good at to the
point and
you know it's because i i worked at it
and i got really good at just relaxing
and staying calm and thinking about
other things
and then when it's time to show up boom
you show up and you compete
well then so we should schedule an
instagram live with you
seven minutes before you go out uh yeah
listen i am so game uh because yes
that's kind of like the stuff that i'll
be doing i'll be playing on twitter or
whatever
it might be harder with boxing gloves so
mma gloves
boxing gloves i don't know how that's
gonna be possible i'll have to like hire
an assistant that just plays with my
phone or something i gotta know too
is is the story that that scott uh
related from chael is it true like did
you
yeah cause he would uh we fought in the
night over there so he would get up
early to watch me
and you know he he listen he actually
just roasted usa wrestling last week
or no he's won championship because he
got the wrong time zone
he did the math wrong he rose to one
championship but he would always get the
math wrong
he'd be like hey you fight and i'm like
nah it's not for four hours or something
like you're up at three a.m but
i don't fight till like six am or
whatever you know and so then we would
text and
he always he you know he also he
habitually stays up for
uh wrestling tournaments so like a lot
of the world championships wrestling are
like in europe or in asia or whatever
he'll you know he'll be up all night and
so like you know sometimes it'll be like
2am and i'll be texting him about the
wrestling because i'm
also obsessed with wrestling and uh yeah
he's up all night watching
that's good that's great go ahead uh
what's your favorite social media
platform i see you love twitter
twitter by far twitter by far you know i
don't really like instagram
uh the people on there have too low of
iq the comments are terrible
um twitter is a place where you can kind
of
interact more and get i want to get full
thoughts out because it's only 280
characters but you can get like
a thought and go back and forth with
people um i find that to be hard to do
on instagram
okay yeah i gotta check this clubhouse
thing out i heard clubhouse is cool i'm
actually using it for the first time
tonight so
oh okay yeah all right have you guys
done that i've done clubhouse i i
it's you can't save it it's just audio
social media and uh it's kind of like
the comment section of a youtube video
but like out loud out loud yeah
so i i got off of it all right so
it's actually i heard it got really
popular and then it's kind of went down
in the last couple weeks but i think
like
like a month ago people were going nuts
over it i i heard about it yeah it's
good during a pandemic
so uh so now did it help me with what
we're promoting we've got the
cryptocurrency podcast what's that
called
i got the fun it's the funky crypto show
i just it goes right onto my
uh twitter on mondays okay the funky
crypto show
on ben askren's twitter on mondays so
everything starts on twitter we're
following
funky ben and then where can we watch
the fight uh
trailer i don't know
i'm gonna be there i don't need to watch
you guys i'll be i'll be there live
they gave me a bunch of money not a
percentage so [ __ ] who watches it
that's great you know if they gave me a
percentage i would know exactly how to
find them
yeah driving
yeah all right and uh did did uh logan
paul win you over on impulsive that was
good
uh yeah he was who's cool i think they
you know they thought they were gonna
[ __ ] with me a little bit and it was
like
it was uh it just didn't work i mean i
i don't know you're just into the
impenetrable unfazable
dorky cool yeah yeah where does that
come from like your composure even
during the jake paul or
you know the press conference which like
it's it's kind of a shame that that's
so rare to see in people these days but
just that someone can keep their
composure stay calm and like let [ __ ]
just bounce off of them
like where's that have you always been
that way so i i go all the way back for
me and i don't if you guys remember
these days
but and someone kids won't list listen
to this probably remember there was
these things called message boards
they kind of still exist but not really
right
and i was fit i was 15 years old and i
was going to the state tournament high
school state tournament wrestling
and someone said hey man they got these
new message boards and everyone's
talking about you
and there were these two seniors and i
was a sophomore and everyone's saying
these seniors are gonna whip my ass so
i'm like
[ __ ] these people and i got on there and
i'm like i'm gonna whoop their ass blah
blah blah
and all these adults just said oh
he's the worst guy he's so cocky he's
this he's that and it's like
to me it was like you know again that
group mentality like
you know i look back that was a 15 year
old kid like i didn't know what i was
doing like i just saw some people
talking [ __ ] and i talked [ __ ] back
so then the next two years my high
school career was like what can i do to
upset these people the most you know
like this general adult public of
wisconsin wrestling and so that kind of
was my intro to
people aren't logical they're not
reasonable they're just going to go
very emotional and see what you know say
whatever they feel and it doesn't it
shouldn't really bother me
right and i didn't didn't ever let it
bother me um
and that was kind of the start of it you
know and then it's just like
i don't know why would i let what
someone else is saying bother me i'm
good i'm good with who i am and uh
that's it
yeah dude what it did yeah funky ben
asking
funky ben asker man i'm a fan brother
i'm a fan
and i appreciate it yeah but and then by
all means dude
you got my cell number [ __ ] you know
hit me up any time i i'd love to meet up
i'm rooting for you this weekend but
honestly i'm just going to tell you the
truth
i'm happy either way if you win i'm
super happy for the the mma community
and and the sort of the rejoicing the
world will do
and if jake paul wins you know what like
let him turn into a hype train because
it's fascinating
you got it yeah i appreciate you guys
i'm a big fan also
um i hope he doesn't turn into a hype
train uh
but there i've i'll acknowledge that's a
possibility and then uh yeah hopefully
we can get together and throw some disc
golf or uh or
maybe we put an outfit on and pranks
people yeah i don't work on that
cauliflower here yeah i don't know
that's
it i'll give you some cauliflower
everybody says that
i only just looked at your ear dude it
looks like [ __ ] a disaster
there's one right there and then this
one i got a microphone but there's
yeah i got my brothers are way bigger my
brother has like they like stick
way out i mean wrestling he can do it
right
wrestling's the way to do it dude yeah
mushroom
[ __ ] failed
i didn't get [ __ ] for cauliflower here
before everybody failed
everybody everything everybody's failed
man some ears just won't do it but yeah
we'll do a bunch of fun [ __ ] man all
right we'll let you get to your day man
thank you again for this man big boy
that was awesome appreciate it guys
thanks ben thanks ben peace
man i really like that guy you know and
i really like
you as well for sticking around to the
end of the podcast
on the last podcast mark cuban some of
you guys who stuck around to the end
we're making fun of my skateboarding and
that hurting man
you know but like i took it on the chin
it's all good
i put it out there and i care about you
know my skateboarding
i'm really uh trying hard wait until you
see
how hard i'm trying it's crazy and uh
if it's too bright when when you're
looking maybe wear some steep
sunglasses we got them back in stock
dude super stoked man
9.99 dude